a London artist is developing colors for
palates that have mostly faded from
memory he's bringing back to life
pastels and other hues that so many
people have attached to the past
Jonathan Vigliotti has the story inside
an East London studio you'll find a
kaleidoscope of powder that when mixed
and mashed reveal rare shades from the
past
Bucky making centric painting is like
cooking you Pedro de Costa Felger is is
equal parts artist and Alchemist this is
the device which is Roberts can-do
rabbit skin glue the most ancient kind
of paint medium you can you can you can
use for the pigment pigment that were
popular centuries ago but have faded
over time as a conservatory
it's Felger is his job to first research
and match time periods with their
appropriate pigments than following
ancient paint recipes brain Historic
Landmarks back to their original
grandeur as staff at London's 18th
century Strawberry Hill House have
learned authenticity can have its own
unique scent
the volunteers kind of excited
complaining what I smell is a very pity
snow actually I found them going around
fresh which is the last thing you should
do in our historical house because the
surface of the paint that smell
depending on the colour could come from
any number of unusual ingredients
cochineal is made with crushed beetles
verted err which is the result of a
chemical reaction with copper sulphate
is known for the amount of elbow grease
that goes into it
Felger is only knows one man who has the
patience to make it by hand he's very
happy to be up all night for three weeks
they can go and store it every hour
because every hour 24 hours a day apart
is what he tells me
wow that is commitment to color Felger
is his passion for color began when he
was a kid growing up in the vibrant
streets of Lisbon Portugal the city he
says hasn't done enough to preserve its
history I remember every single Villa
before he got knocked down I still
remember the colors vividly I mean I
remember the purples the Greens the
yellows
his latest project has in preserving a
piece of London's past this massive
dragon will join dozens of others on top
of the pagoda in Kew Gardens all of them
replacing identical ones removed over a
century ago this building is represented
China within Kew Gardens because Felger
has identified the colors that would
have likely been used in the 1700s
vibrant greens and reds as an artist as
an historian this is quite a grand
display for you well yes I'm proud to be
part of it but it's not about me is
about the buildings and their past
getting a fresh coat of old paint for
CBS this morning Saturday Jonathan
Vigliotti London that's a commitment to
paint like once an hour for 24 hours for
three weeks yeah it would not happen in
my world beautiful but the colors are
stuff